et aujourd'hui avait lieu la rentrée des
classes pour 12 millions d'élèves et
leurs enseignants
sauf que cette rentrée n'avait rien
d'ordinaire d'abord à cause de la
situation sanitaire avec une france qui
fait face à son deuxième confinement et
mais aussi avec une france bien sûr on
dit par la mort du professeur d'histoire
samuel pâtit pour l'occasion tous les
établissements ont rendu hommage au
professeur ou vous résume la rentrée
scolaire mouvementée dans un petit sujet
on aura benjamin a marqué notre témoin
du jour qui nous dévoilera les détails
de cette journée juste après regarde ce
lundi matin été marqué par un événement
majeur la rentrée des classes ou le
second confinement à la rentrée des
classes
une rentrée scolaire la rentrée scolaire
une rentrée très particulière car elle
était aussi l'occasion de rendre un
hommage national à samuel pâtit ce
professeur d'histoire victimes du
terrorisme islamiste
une minute de silence a été observée
dans toutes les salles de classe du pays
une rentrée qui était aussi celle du
respect des règles sanitaires dans une
france en partie confiné si les élèves
et les professeurs ont l'autorisation de
se rendre dans les établissements
scolaires en france un protocole
exceptionnel a été mis en place par le
gouvernement des règles similaires aux
gestes barrières habituel même si pour
cette rentrée le port du masque est
obligatoire pour les élèves dès le cp
les élèves et le personnel éducatif
doivent aussi se laver les mains
régulièrement respecter les east
barrière éviter les rassemblements et
conserver leurs masques tant que
possible des gestes pas toujours faciles
à respecter dans des établissements
plein à craquer alors protocole
sanitaire hommage à samuel pâtit la
rentrée des classes est elle réussie
alors justement damas ammar professeur
d'histoire dans un lycée merci benjamin
d'être avec nous notre premier témoin du
jour puisqu'il n'aura un tous les jours
pas vraiment amar alors déjà vous avez
fait votre concret vous aujourd'hui
tout à fait cette professeur d'histoire
dans le 94 c'est un créteil exactement
alors déjà il y avait une émotion
certainement ce matin comment s'est
passé le matelassé mais elle pâtit
c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est quand on
s'est retrouvé en salle des professeurs
à 10 heures puisque l'hommage avait lieu
à 11h les collègues avaient un sentiment
un goût de cendre dans la bouche parce
que en réalité c'était très très
compliqué où il ya eu toute une série de
péripéties quand même un sur la manière
dont l'hommage était alors de parler des
élèves devaient rentrer à 10 heures
réellement ils sont entre à 8 heures
exactement
donc voila c est le temps le ski
devaient être justement un hommage
collectif à la fin une fine et les
collègues se sont trouvés tout seul
dans l'eure dans leur salle de cours
avec une minute de silence et une lettre
une lettre de jaurès à lire et moi
j'avais des collègues qui étaient la
boule au ventre parce qu'ils aient mais
face à cette situation elle est d'une
violence inouïe
moi je suis enseignant d'histoire ce
jour où j'ai appris qu'un de mes
collègues s'étaient retrouvés décapités
en 2020 pour avoir c'est son boulot
parce qu'on est des dizaines de milliers
à avoir fait ce qu'a fait ça mais elle
pâtit
vous avez des élèves de lycée ce travail
sur la liberté d'expression en
travaillons sur les caricatures de
manière large mais y compris avec celle
de charlie hebdo je les fais comme
l'accord des dizaines de milliers de
collègues et j'étais en salle des profs
avec mais avec mes collègues et jordi
alors comment ça va se passer il y en
avait jusque là bord tout le monde mais
pas prof d'histoire géo et puis il y en
a qui étaient kingdom je ne sais pas ce
que je vais venir et avait le sentiment
d'avoir été envoyés au casse-pipe
si vous voulez on a eu un hommage comme
ça ça a été omniprésent mais après dans
la réalité du terrain quand vous êtes
face aux élèves les prix les collègues
ont eu le sentiment d'être laissés
livrés à eux mêmes
il faut donner du sens à ce qui n'en a
pas c'est ça qu'on doit faire à damas
est ce que vous êtes posé la question
vous depuis ce drame
est ce que vous êtes dit je vais changer
moi aussi mes méthodes est-ce que je
vais continuer à faire le programme tel
qu'il est ou je vais essayer de contrer
bonne question
alors ça c'est une très bonne question
c'est une très bonne question parce que
là on rentre dans la vraie vie
moi je pense que bien évidemment il faut
continuer à tenir la position parce que
finalement c'est le sens de la lettre de
jaurès c'est une lettre très compliqué à
faire comprendre que son élève
c'est le sens c'est à dire que forment à
la citoyenneté et donc on peut pas
lâcher cette position là c'est pas
possible
mais derrière quand on regarde
l'histoire de samuel pâtit quand même
quand on regarde les faits quand on sait
quand on s'intéresse au déroulé cet
homme il a été laissé tout seul à la fin
que lui dit l'institution
même si la chef d'établissement elle a
été à ses côtés que lui dit
l'institution
écoutez monsieur pâtit il va falloir
changer le trajet pour arriver au lycée
mettez vous une capuche
voilà dix recrues on voit bien dans le
déroulé que les dix jours de cet homme
ont été d'une immense solitude et ce qui
se passe c'est que derrière au moment de
de rendre hommage il ya un sentiment
d'être passés complètement à côté moi je
je les écris jeu c'est un hommage
moi j'estime complètement bâclé est-ce
que derrière on a réussi à donner sens
aux élèves qu'il aurait fallu faire
est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire alors tu
as déjà ce qui était prévu au départ
était pas mal c'est à dire qu' il y
avait effectivement quelque chose de
collectif
c'est ça oui comment vous retrouver seul
face à vos élèves dans une situation
aussi dramatique quand vous êtes je ne
sais pas moi par exemple le professeur
de svt ou professeur d'espagnol
vous n'avez pas forcément tous les
éléments là dessus et vous vous dites
mais qu'est ce que je vais bien pouvoir
leur dire surtout que n'y a pas mal
d'élèves qui n'ont pas les éléments qui
n'ont pas la connaissance exacte de ce
qui s'est passé
enfin la c1 mais ils souhaitent essayer
de autour de vous de discuter avec un
adolescent de ce qui s'est passé vous
avez vous allez la sortie remplacé d'en
avoir un en témoin du jour cette semaine
comme elle a reçu ses villages la force
de la cohésion et voir un groupe parler
et écouter qui aurait été plus fort
c'est ça oui bienvenue alors bien
évidemment travailler collectivement et
puis et puis travailler sur le long
terme quand même parce que là je suis
sain afin bien sûr une minute de silence
une lecture de jaurès à les lire la gsl
et est ce que est ce qu un moment quand
j'ai passé ce drame est ce que vous êtes
bien moment j'ai plus envie de faire ce
métier
charles a certainement pas ce métier
c'est une passion et c'est une question
que ddd des fascistes totalitaire arrive
à obtenir cette victoire donc non il ne
faut pas mais il faut but qu'on parle de
cela comprendre que le monde enseignant
est né dans un malaise qui est assez
proche des personnels soignants en ce
moment quand vous êtes enseignant vous
vous retrouvez avec à la fois ce drame
qui posera un plein de problèmes en
terme de sécurité et d'intégrité des
personnes et puis la question du
protocole sanitaire
donc si vous voulez vous avez une double
chape de plomb c'est ça avec ses vous
faisiez un peu un dossier sarr son
protocole sanitaire qui a changé dans
les entende parler justement on va en
parler dans un instant parce que c'est
vrai que le protocole sanitaire
vous allez nous dire si pour vous c'est
il est bien respectée si elle vraiment
des règles strictes dans votre lycée par
exemple pour vous
li d'après ce qu'on m'a dit c'est win it
c'est une énorme mascarade
vous allez nous en parler dans un
instant